now if you enjoy what we do here at
spectator tv why not take out a
subscription
to the spectator magazine it's the
fastest growing current affairs
publication in europe and within its
pages and
on our website you can read all your
favorite spectator
tv contributors we'll even throw in a 20
pound
amazon gift voucher all for free if you
sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk tv offer or just google spectator
tv
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
12 pounds
plus a free 20 pound amazon voucher
do the arithmetic it's a no-brainer
[Music]
now so far on this edition of spectator
tv we've
not mentioned covert or at least covered
it
uh but i'm afraid we are going to now
uh this week boris johnson said that the
fall in cases and hospitalizations
uh and deaths was not a result of the
vaccine roll out
uh i think many people will be surprised
by that
but regardless of what boris the
epidemiologist thinks
what is the data show uh let's go to
kate andrews now our economics editor
and editor
of our lunchtime briefing email with the
latest data from the spectators
covered data hub thanks andrew yes
very strange comments from the prime
minister this week putting essentially
all the focus on lockdowns
for the progress we've made in tackling
the virus so far instead of vaccines
so let's have a quick look at the data
and where we are now before we dig into
that
as you can see from this first slide
infections are down 97
from the peak of the most recent wave
here we're looking at the seven day
rolling average and current infection
rates are roughly around where they were
at the very start of september last year
on this next slide those being admitted
to hospital for covet are down 96
from the january peak also hovering
around early september
rates and deaths down a staggering 98
from the peak london has reported zero
cova deaths
for several days this month including
twice this week
now that can always be revised upwards
so we take it with a pinch of salt
but it certainly enhances the narrative
that the virus is really on the retreat
so is this success story playing out
across europe the answer is sadly no
andrew
the grass i've shown reflected the uk
has experienced one of the fastest falls
in case rates around the world and now
as you can see here currently has the
lowest
case rate in europe but other countries
like france are still struggling
to get their cases under control so if
you compare the uk here with the lowest
case rates to this next slide
where we have the highest rate for
vaccination in europe by a long way
this brings us on to the prime
minister's comments this week about what
to credit for our success in tackling
kovid
this time around now the uk for months
this winter was in one of the strictest
lockdowns in the developed world and
no doubt that played a big role in
bringing numbers down
that's what lockdowns do they suppress
the virus but they can't eliminate it
that wasn't really the controversial
part of his comment it was the emphasis
he was putting on vaccines
not playing a crucial role in this story
so far
and they're comments that head of the
nhs sir simon stevens has countered
perhaps not intentionally but certainly
in effect
by stating after the pm's comments that
quote vaccines are successfully reducing
hospitalizations and deaths
amongst the cohorts that have had the
vaccine end quote
and those are of course the people who
are the most vulnerable because we've
prioritized the vaccine for the elderly
and those most vulnerable
to having a severe reaction to this
virus in the first place
and the ons infection survey backs this
up
as you can see from this graph here it's
now estimated that roughly half of
britons have antibody prevalence
with one in two people in england
scotland wales and northern ireland
thought to have antibodies and crucially
it's people in the most elderly age
brackets that have the most prevalence
and this is something that sir simon
stevens was also keen to highlight
saying quote data that we have analyzed
shows a 75 percent
reduction in emergency covert
hospitalizations for the vaccine cohorts
and as more and more people are
vaccinated that effect will
widen and quote so what do we make of
this
to be honest it's very hard to
disentangle the lockdown effect and the
vaccine factor this time around
the odd thing wasn't that the pm was
giving credit to lockdown but that he
once again deliberately
was playing down the vaccines this isn't
a one-off for about a month now this
kind of rhetoric
has been on the rise with lots of focus
on vaccines not being 100
effective from both the pm and his
officials
now that is a true statement but still a
very strange one because nobody ever
ever thought we'd get a vaccine with 100
efficacy that the vaccines we're using
are as effective as they are
based on the data we currently have is
really nothing short
of a scientific miracle so the question
now
is why is there all this caution around
talking up
the vaccines what's behind this is there
real data-driven concern in downing
street
about the possibility of a new variant
that can undermine vaccines
is this an attempt to keep people
following the rules for a bit longer for
as long
as possible really as their older
relatives are getting that protection
through the vaccine and
they're fearful that people might start
taking the rules and taking their life
into their own hands once again
well either way that's probably the
conversation and the honesty that the pm
should be having with the nation rather
than what we're getting now which is
quite a muddled rhetoric with the
vaccine which so far
is proving to be a big success story
back over to you andrew
[Music]
you